[Music]
hello my name's Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm joined
here with a friend and colleague of mine
a [ __ ] devoted Sookie who is the sig
co-chair of sig p.m. and the CN CF CN CF
s-- representation here at the
conference right right yeah my name is
Sarah baretsky I'm a developer advocate
at CN CF and I'm a quarter of 6:00 p.m.
the product management sig was in the
humanities community right so I want to
talk about sig p.m. so sig stands for
special interest groups PM is product
management you're the co-chair full
disclosure I've participated in that
community a bit I'd like you to tell us
a little bit about the Charter and the
definition of that group sure so let's
start with from from the entire
community how communities community is
formed and what are the atomic units of
kubernetes communities so sig is a
special interest group it's a it's a
small small unit but the basic unit of
community so every single piece of
kubernetes is being developed by some
special interest group it can there can
be some technical and vertical six there
called the vertical six that are focused
on some specific technical errors of
specific component of communities for
example if you are looking for the
special interest group which is
developing for the for example network
and functionality or storage
functionality there are sig net work or
six storage within the cabinet yeah I
find that super unique right I mean it
makes perfect sense to have a special
interest group working on networking are
working on storage you're working on
GPUs or accelerators but this is a
special interest work group for an open
source project that's a group of product
managers from lots of competing
companies working on how to improve
product management around kubernetes
right so product management group is
really a unique group within the cabinet
is community and we and within the
entire open source world because usually
open source projects are simply projects
but other companies are building their
own products on top of them we have a
goal of building communities as a solid
product even a fully open source that
other companies that
show companies can reuse them in their
product offerings and we have multiple
representatives from the multiple
companies who are working together in in
this single direction so 6:00 p.m. as a
product management sig was established
well it was established original as a
working group not as a sig so we've been
simply the group of people who've been
interested in working on the features
and roadmap for kubernetes and we've
developed and we've established the
community's product management working
group around two years ago and actually
some Google representatives were one of
the one of the initiators of the drive
what do you see is the key output of
this group
so the key output for us is driving the
features and developing the solid
roadmap for Cuban artists for the new
year's time for the new year's here
probably for the next few years and the
another output is to provide some solid
information for the end users and for
the vendor companies who will reuse
kubernetes for their purposes so just
like product management at any one of
our independent companies Google
Microsoft any of the other contributors
but for the community for the CNC F
community exactly so we have two major
touch points way from one site we are
speaking with end-user community with
the people who are only using it and
consuming it and from the other side we
are working closely with the technical
teams who are developing some
functionality so we are as the SiC
VMware simply the proxy between the end
users between vendors between their
service providers that are built in some
services a product set up of communities
and the technical groups who are
developing some functionality for
communities and within communities yeah
there's a fascinating project and I hope
that if this group is successful we'll
see similar groups emerge around other
open-source projects egoriy thank you
very much for your time
you